very well deserving hall-of-famer good
friend Dick Vitale here on the program
how are you dick EB I'm doing really
well you know kind of a funny day I was
on get up just wanted week reading it it
work came down and ship a high and last
I was involved right or accident that
cost the life of an individual and
certainly our prayers go out to the
individual lost his life and a Frizzle
squad the gym right now like those got
to be devastated but I know you wanted
to excite and we should join SIA dancer
it's become a hot topic now a lot of
people say if I should pack it up you
should play anymore I think it's
ridiculous rich I think it's ridiculous
when you have a love for the game what
about being you know not being selfish
that this is a beautiful kid I mean we
don't know all the medical reports yet
we haven't heard the final analysis with
the doctors in the MRI but if he is no
structural damage and it's what they
think a mile stream and the kid wants to
play what's wrong with that well I mean
this this could also be just as we all
know dick as you've seen the worldwide
leader explode and then their shows like
this having platforms and so many other
people on on Twitter having an ability
to cast opinions as I said earlier in
the show we have no idea if Zion just
knows right now he has every intention
of plane I mean and we're just all
filling the void until we know for sure
with the constant conversation if we've
seen play out a lot in college football
to dick where a lot of future draftees
don't want to put anything on the line
for any sport where they're not getting
paid so let me just ask you this
question
I mean if Zion decides to decides to sit
you you do I heard you use the word
selfish you think it would be selfish if
he does decide to do that well you know
let me let me put it this way number one
first of all I think Mark Emmert of the
NCAA should get a message for this loud
and clear I've been saying so many times
rich I firmly believe it I kid like
Zionist and face the face this year of
college basketball I wasn't with the
spring training camp spent some time
they went to Garth Brooks and everybody
at the Pittsburgh training camp was
coming up to me the first question will
Dickie Bebo's I and he's unbelievable
Zion what kind of Pro Zion Zion Zion a
kid like Zion should be allowed or any
players should be allowed on the
collegiate level if they can do with
door secrets and if they can go out
curent banquets autograph sessions and
get paid so be it
what's the big deal if Dillon Smith was
a student she without the bitter concert
as a student and get zillions of dollars
that's okay but I don't want to see the
logic they keep saying well they don't
have money to pay these athletes but you
gotta really you gotta pay everybody
whether it be lacrosse baseball bezel
well eliminate day you have to pay
anybody and the second factor is Richard
I firmly believe this
a kid like Sonia should be allowed to
get money from an Asian if an agent
wants to give them cash let me tell you
this it would eliminate all this get up
I just chilling you were former player
think about this you know that there's
so many shady deals go on behind the
scenes
well this flipping cash to people
parents etc shoe companies eliminate
this reason is saying you know what if
an agent wants to give the kid cash let
him give it to all I mean I I really if
you want to keep these kids and a third
thing that really has troubled me for
many a year is the fact that the
wouldn't done is a laughingstock to
college sports it really is it makes a
mockery out of the term student-athlete
they should allow kids like Zion to have
to make a decision out of high school if
they want to go to the NBA
our LeBron James Kobe Bryant let them go
look I have no problem with that but I
think if a kid comes to cause IRA
problem with the football situation I'll
be honestly I have a total problem they
lead your team from a ball game and then
they walk out on their team I mean that
is you don't teach those values in life
do you
where's the moral values about what
about quitting and thinking about
yourself and they're your teammates I
have a problem with that I really do an
injury let me tell you this rich he has
a better chance of not getting injured
playing the destruction environment that
unstructured cuz you know and I know any
kid that's not going to play and is in
good shape to play
we'll be out there working out like
crazy working out like crazy so I don't
buy their argument if he's hurt and he
can't play that's one thing but if he
can't play I think and I was gonna be a
problem was I because he's already said
when Scottie Pittman said that he should
close it down during the middle of the
year cuz the stock was so high he came
out very strong so I'm not walking away
of my teammates and my coaches are
people cuz I love being again loved
being a student
what is wrong loving being a student I
could go on all day with this rich I
don't want to take I love it Dickie v I
really I really really do I mean there
was a lot to unpack there so I'll just I
guess leave it there for the moment and
ask you I guess the basketball question
how surprised were you and obviously you
know nobody expects a shoe to explode
and the kid to be gone just less than a
minute into the game
how Duke just with all of their stud
players that are still you know left to
play that they got blown out last night
by North Carolina I think mentally you
know rich I think there's no doubt in my
mind is a former coach what a deflated
moment that was in a game it's a bigger
game you got the former president there
you got people paying thousands of
dollars to see this game to basically
see Zion and I'm telling you but that
happened so really I think it took so
much out of it but to say it all that I
was on SportsCenter earlier before the
game and I said the one area you know if
Duke place their a game they beat
anybody with their full cast but but
they've had trouble during here
when it in consistency of shooting two
three it's been a problem and if they're
not doing that it could be a problem
here in this game well they go eight for
39 in first one Zion plays they don't
take thirty nine threes because he gives
a Productivity inside the three
three-second area but you got a credit
certainly Luca Bay was terrific
so was Cameron Johnson their whole team
played exceptionally well defensively
and offensively you got a credit North
Carolina but there's no doubt anybody
wounds to be the first to tell you
they're a different team when signing on
the sidelines but they're still very
talented he said that after the game
last night let's be honest once the ions
out it makes things different
but that said you know I mean there's
all those fabulous freshmen that that do
care and I'm wondering what Coach K what
do you think's going through his temples
knowing him as well as you do what's
going through his mind this morning dick
well I think first of all these concern
right now certainly science status to
make sure the kid is okay and everybody
does the right thing and I know he's so
close to GPA I'm I guarantee it that's
on his mind
big time and thinking about the the
individual that lost his life in that
situation you know yeah Jim situation
but you got a family there that got
notified that their loved one was God
and no one the kind of guy Mike is
that's running through his mind however
saying all that if they ever play maybe
two weeks or so when I was hired he's
working on an adjustment stage in going
through a scenario you know it happened
so quick you don't have a time to adjust
I mean you're not just losing a normal
player I'm you losing the best player in
the nation number one draft choice and
now it's a suck all the kids but I'll
agree we this talent is three guys three
guys you lined up out of five at 60% are
gonna be MBA first rounders and two but
we're going in a top five in the draft I
mean a lot of coaches wish they had it
so they're not gonna be a lot of tears
shed for Duke over the scenario in terms
of hey they still got talent yeah they
sure do and now and and again you know
the sooner we hear about Zions health
the quicker we could put all this stuff
to bed but it really is amazing how many
people's first reaction was he shouldn't
play anymore dick that it's over because
he's so really I don't know Knox I don't
understand and I'll be honestly rich I
really have a problem with that ever
problems football I've always been a
believer you don't teach people to quit
you don't teach people you have a
commitment your commitment should be
honored you know I'd be something else
oppose me and I know I'm way off base
with this maybe I'm old-fashioned I
don't know but it bothers you when he
can't commit
Rich Eisen commits the biskits verbally
you're a great great player you can
verbally you see I'm Dominican and you
taking all these other campuses I find
that almost is there
I mean it's ridiculous if a kid commits
don't you commit I mean know everybody
of the coaches I get I hear you dick I'm
sure many people who are hearing this
conversation might be saying to their
radios or their television sets
what about coaches who who let the kids
commit and then they they take a job
that that's better
apparently I mean what happens there I
agree in fact about two months ago and I
firmly believe this I believe this okay
we have right now waivers kids applied
for waivers if a kid transfers the great
player from - aren't you the quarterback
transferred Ohio State and his lawyer
how to submit a waiver request for him
to be ultra obediently well you know
verifier left they went to Florida to
coach or go today he was coaching yes he
does apply for any waiver my point is
you know what if a kid wants to transfer
he transfers and coach you all be chaos
oh really
well if you have a great relationship
with the kids is he comfortable at the
university he's not going to leave but
if he does feel uncomfortable why
shouldn't he be allowed to leave without
apply it for waivers I couldn't agree
more with what you said no nice so so
but wouldn't that in a way we mean that
they're not fulfilling their commitment
their verbal commitment where it's just
something has to have it changed since
their verbal commitment in terms of what
their playing time or you know I'm just
want to get well yeah you know you find
out it's not a verbal commitment anymore
now it's a scenario where you actually
committed decided to go to that school
you go to the air but you meet with the
coach and you find out I mean life a lot
of times we find out there may be
situations all right what they are I
mean there's the forces marriages
scenarios weird things don't work out
many times many times their coach will
almost support that decision because
usually the decision for a kid transfer
it is based one way it's usually our
playing time you see I came here with
great an excitement I thought I was
gonna be a final factor and now maybe
I'm on the third team or fourth team in
football not even getting on the field
so maybe I'm better off going elsewhere
and I think any coach would support the
the book dick fights house mount
Rushmore's of college basketball solid
gold primetime performers from my four
decades at ESPN co-authored
dick hoops Weiss in the research by the
great Schwaab himself Howie Schwab
that's awesome dick and dick vitally
excited about you I really give it a
check for twenty four thousand six
hundred hours and my wife told me just
the other day we're gonna be sending
another picture to the V Foundation so
every dollar I would make rich every
sixty cents will go for kids battling
cancer which is something that's all
right
special to me we got my big gala coming
up on bay roderick donald sweeney chris
power avery johnson we give it out John
Saunders Awards and John's name for
courage to Holly Rowe at the Lee Corso
and that's going to be a special
sold-out nine hundred people you got an
open invitation man I think I love an
open invitation to be a guest
I wonder against the lab speaking about
sixty celebs it's a great night Saturday
come to my house casual dress we have a
party for all the cancer kids that are
with us with all the deep Foundation
Board of Directors and all the
celebrities you got an open thanks dick
I really appreciate that you know I
thought of last night I always think of
this because I was always sitting on the
Sports Center set after you would call
in a big game like last night throw into
it I thought Stewart would have really
obviously he would have been just as
shocked and crazed as everybody else
watching Zion but seeing UNC win a big
game and Duke I thought of sue Scott no
doubt about it you know hey injuries or
way of life that's what's right you got
to respond
you got to respond yes with a few uh
Booya
we would have heard that that's for sure
I think I love you thanks for calling do
you take care yourself thanks rich send
me text wise your address I want to sit
your horrible it fights right yeah I
would love that
thanks dick I appreciate that I got it
that's Dickey via TV on Twitter Dickie v
underscore ESPN on Instagram and of
course go to dick vital online.com or
wherever books are sold to go get tix
book all the funds go towards the great
V foundation for cancer research the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience
you